قصه نجاه الاطفال من ادغال كولومبيا ملهمه
بالتاكيد وهناك قصص اخرى شبيهه لعمليه
انقاذ رماتيكيه شهدت اهتماما عالميا كبيرا
وقتها القصه الاشهر من تايلند وتحديدا في
يونيو عام 2018 حين تم انقاذ فريق لكره
القدم 12 طفلا ومدربهم بعد ما علقوا بداخل
كهف غمرتهم
17 يوما وفي 2010 امضى 33 رجلا من عمال
المناجم في تشيلي اكثر من شهرين تحت الارض
بعد انهيار منجم سان خوسيه للتنقيب عن
النحاس والذهب واستغرق انتشار جميع العمال
حوالي 22 ساعه اخيرا عام
1987 سقطت بيبي جيسيكا رضيعه بالغه من
العمر 18 شهرا في بئر بالحديقه الخلفيه
لمنزل خالتها في تكساس وحرره عمال الانقاذ
بعد يومين ونصف
عمليه الانقاذ هذه وذيعت وقتها على الهواء
مباشره لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار
والبرامج والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات
والتقارير الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في
قناتنا على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب
وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات